[Music]
is that a different camera jean-luc
Emily you are gonna change the cameras
Jesus that's beautiful that's the Sony's
yeah those are so nice those are
fantastic those are excellent it looks
different well yeah it's got a different
base frame look at it look at the base
frame on it what happened what happened
Jeanne why did they change weird because
these are fantastic I've requested these
the X 80s they have standard bear
resolution standard they're also known
for their huh
they have 9g pixel control those are
fantastic Jeff do you know about this
they changed our cameras out what's
going on you didn't know who's running
this thing oh man this getting ripped
off left and right they're all clamoring
why you guys been real quiet
did you sell our cameras while we were
gone you guys are all I feel like we
caught you doing something yeah maybe we
had a wedding job this weekend then they
couldn't get the stuff back from Agoura
Hills
I just want to know what's happening I
know
wait these are the same so a second ago
there were different cameras and now
you're saying you're the same cameras no
those have different no it's like a
different view finder yeah it's got a
viewfinder it's got a different chassis
I'm getting a lot of double-talk
all right well we'll find out what you
guys are up to but so help me God well
come on down the jeans use camera
warehouse yeah ask for Costa he'll treat
your real
[Laughter]
[Music]